[Música]
hola muchas gracias por seguir en la
pantalla de france en 24 comenzamos
ahora 5 minutos con un espacio de france
24 con entrevistas breves a expertos en
diversas temáticas que ocupan un lugar
central en la agenda global hoy vamos a
abordar la apertura en el turismo en la
región luego de la pandemia de
coronavirus kovic 19 y es por eso que
nos acompaña a aldo elías el ex
presidente de la cámara argentina de
turismo la cat y de la federación
sudamericana de turismo fedetur aldo
elías muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 muy buen día
gracias bueno señor elías el turismo ya
estaba viéndose muy afectado en todo el
mundo
cuéntenos cuál es la situación en
particular en argentina no teniendo en
cuenta que estamos en la temporada
invernal no que tradicionalmente llena
de turistas las zonas de aquí como por
ejemplo la patagonia del país al sur
estamos asistiendo a una temporada en
donde está completamente perdida toda la
actividad turística en la argentina en
particular tenemos 40 y no obligatoria
desde el día 19 de marzo y estamos con
facturación cero desde ese momento y
quizás por bastante tiempo más porque la
situación sanitaria no mejora estamos
justo en el medio del invierno y hemos
perdido una de las mejores temporadas de
nieve de los últimos 10 años a la usted
de facturación pero maneja las cifras de
pérdidas
el año pasado la argentina en la
argentina ingresaron alrededor de 5.400
millones de dólares en concepto de
turismo este año no creemos que vaya a
superar los 800 hay un prácticamente un
20 por ciento hoteles que no van a
volver a abrir y la situación realmente
para graficar la también habla de cerca
de 90 mil puestos de trabajo perdidos ya
ahora y dentro de todo lo que es el
sector turismo no que engloba como usted
decía diversas tareas quiénes son los
más perjudicados
no hay diferencias porque el estar en
facturación cero los guías de las
empresas de transporte turísticos los
hoteles los restaurantes las agencias de
viajes estamos todos en la misma
situación y en una situación
absolutamente crítica si no realizadas
qué alternativas o qué salida se
encuentra usted a esta crisis
a nivel local estamos trabajando la
reapertura a través de corredores
turísticos interprovinciales pretendemos
hacer lo mismo a nivel regional a abrir
protocolos perdón a abrir con corredores
turísticos inter regionales que nos
permitan de alguna manera a través de
protocolos y respeto absoluto a las
disposiciones de los ministerios de
salud de cada uno de los países que
fueran a participar e intentar
establecer de nuevo la actividad
turística que es central porque es la
más transversal de todas las actividades
económicas de cada uno de los países que
componen la fe de sus también hablaba
usted recién de medias a nivel regional
no quisiera profundizar un poco más en
este tema porque como decía en la
presentación ustedes
también el presidente de la federación
sudamericana de turismo como ve entonces
la apertura del sector más allá de
argentina no en toda la región
de alguna manera apostando a estos
corredores turísticos sinde provinciales
armar estas burbujas como se llaman
ahora de vuelos entre los países de la
región
por supuesto que burbujas que permitan
estos vuelos en situaciones sanitarias
similares de más está decir que ningún
país de los que integra la fe de sur va
a exponer a su población haciendo
estos vuelos entre países que no cuente
ciudades que no tengan una condición
sanitaria lo más que prolija posible
porque si no estaríamos poniendo en
riesgo al resto de la población y yo no
tendría ningún sentido pero si hay
muchas ciudades que están en condiciones
de empezar a trabajar en esa cuestión
sería necesaria entonces una suerte de
acción coordinada verdad entre los
países de la región cree usted
exactamente desde la fe de sus a nivel
de la representación del sector privado
estamos acompañando a los gobiernos de
cada uno de estos países compartiendo
información compartiendo protocolos
trabajando en una misma línea para poder
a ayudarlos a ellos a tomar la decisión
indicada de abrir estos corredores
turísticos al día muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en france 24 gracias a
ustedes buen día por favor que a usted
en esta audiencia le invitamos por
supuesto a continuar informando se en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]